unsteady on her feet and severely
malnourished Anissa arrives on the wards
the family's village had been cut off by
the fighting in her de de Provence
but somehow she survived doctors want to
examine her what they see is truly
shocking
this is what the world's worst
humanitarian crisis looks like how much
CVD undernourishment
she's eight years old beautiful area how
much
[Music]
with very severe malnutrition they I
have found here they are suspected for
sepsis aren't more likely to die
these patients are more likely to die
she is 10 kg 10.1 kg
she must be 15 you can't imagine this is
the measurement of 2 years 2 years in
the way 2 years without yeah the world
is in the same condition the case from
alpha data from ID visa or the same on
another words the picture is also
distressing this premature baby is just
a few days old
his mother is helping him breathe
because there aren't enough medical
staff to treat everyone countless
children are dying from lack of food and
health care years of conflict have left
the country on the brink of famine and
mostly forgotten by the world
we traveled to the area where the war is
intensifying on the west coast
what is happening in Yemen should shock
the international community some Aid is
getting through but not enough in this
town the distribution center is full of
desperate people there are more mouths
to feed here than there is food and only
those whose names are on the list will
eat everybody else is sent away and aid
agencies a warning
Yemen's crisis could be about to get
worse
the war being bought by Saudi Arabia and
its allies against Iranian backed
ruthie rebels has now shifted to the
coastal plains along the Red Sea
helicopter gunship buzzed the skies
whilst the naval blockade controls the
flow of food Houthi territory is
effectively under siege the west coast
is a vital importance to the saudi-led
coalition the military alliance claims
that if they can control this area and
the port city of her data they can break
the Houthi stranglehold on Sanaa and the
north of the country armed by the United
States and Britain the Coalition is
trying to roll back
Tehran's influence on this part of the
Arabian Peninsula it's not just the sale
of weapons it's also military support to
help prosecute this war
the roads on the way to the front lines
are littered with destroyed armored
vehicles
it is a patchwork of yemeni fighters
though loyal to the government in exile
they're leading the fights Houthi
positions are about a kilometer over
there and they are responding with more
surrounds at the moment they're clearing
the villages around her data but we've
been told by senior commanders that the
main offensive to take the city will
start very soon but it is the impact
this war is having on the civilian
population that is devastating this is
where the shell landed you know even
refugee camps are in the line of fire
this woman's daughter was killed by the
blast gonna have fun I'm reading it and
nearly four years after the saudi-led
coalition entered the war in Yemen there
is no end in sight it's not certain if
this conflict can even be won
what is sure is civilians will continue
to suffer in the wake of this
destructive war Alex Rossi Stein news on
the outskirts of her data